這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
AI 月費吃到飽的時代正在結束：
ChatGPT 加入廣告
200美元的方案也準備砍量
就連堅持不放廣告的 Claude
訂閱補貼也可能撐不久
這張月票的價格，其實三年沒動過
2023年，ChatGPT Plus 每月20美元
Claude Pro 也同價
月費沒漲，但能用多少算力，會變
最先變的是免費版
ChatGPT 2月開始測試廣告，才半年
8月底 OpenAI
就宣稱廣告年化營收速度衝到10億美元
到了10月，OpenAI
宣布預計在月底先於美國小規模測試生圖旁的廣告
那不想看廣告的人呢？
廣告只出現在 Free 和 Go 方案
免費使用者可以改選無廣告模式
代價是訊息額度更少
Plus、Pro、Business、
Enterprise 和 Edu 目前沒有廣告
免費版不看廣告，就只能接受更少功能
付費的人也沒逃過
OpenAI 每月200美元的 Pro
200 價格不變
但10月30日起
GPT-6 Pro 每週訊息從200則砍到100則
同樣的錢，用量只剩一半
所以想用得跟以前一樣多
就得往上爬到每月500美元的 Pro 500
可是獨立研究機構 SemiAnalysis 估算
它的量只比舊的200美元方案多約21%
奇怪的是，開發者用的 API 反而在降價
API 是讓程式照用量呼叫模型、
用多少付多少的介面
GPT-6 Sol 和 Luna 的價格大約減半
Opus 5.5 的表價也降了20%
為什麼月票反而縮水？
SemiAnalysis 估算，同樣每月20美元
Claude Pro 能用約29億 tokens
ChatGPT Plus 只有約10億
差了大約2.9倍
給得這麼大方，代價不小
SemiAnalysis 粗估
Claude 訂閱吃掉 Anthropic
約41.7%的推論算力
卻只帶來約10%營收
這張月票，可能是一筆昂貴的補貼
那 Anthropic 也放廣告呢？
它早就承諾不會，還在超級盃廣告直說：
「廣告會來到 AI，但不會來 Claude」
所以若要降低訂閱補貼
能調的旋鈕就更集中在價格、
額度和模型權限
偏偏 Anthropic 的財務壓力很大
招股書顯示，2025年營收約46億美元
營業損失卻有約80.6億美元
營業損失比營收還大
往後看，10月還有3個日子
會讓免費和付費都更緊：10月9日起
Gemini 免費版預定只剩 Flash-Lite
10月29日，Pro 200 舊額度到期10月底，ChatGPT
預計在美國小規模測試生圖旁的廣告
把這些拼起來，AI
公司正在收回讓使用者靠固定月票大量消耗算力的補貼
免費使用者用注意力付
重度使用者用更高月費付吃到飽
正變成隨時能調整額度的信用池